facebook ceo mark zuckerberg went all
out yesterday to knock down criticism
that his company chooses profit over
user safety zuckerberg told investors
that online issues like polarization and
hate speech are bigger than social media
or any one site he also emphasized the
need for regulation 60 minutes plus
correspond correspondent lori siegel has
been reporting on facebook's critics and
the documents that they use lori good
morning morning rough week for facebook
the company definitely playing some
defense we reported yesterday on
thousands of pages of leaked internal
research from inside facebook they
suggest the company knew its platforms
can fuel hate polarization conspiracy
theories and misinformation but at times
did little to stop it now during
facebook's quarterly earnings call
yesterday zuckerberg adamantly defended
his company take a listen
good fake criticism helps us get better
but my view is that what we're seeing is
a coordinated effort to selectively use
leaked documents to paint a false
picture of our company it makes a good
sound advice to say that we don't sell
these impossible trade-offs because
we're just focused on making money
now facebook whistleblower frances
haugen and brian bolen who spent 11
years building facebook said this isn't
just about cherry picking a couple
documents bolin told us that time and
time again facebook shows keeping people
engaged on the platform over reducing
harmful content zuckerberg also laid out
a vision for the platform's future
calling young users ages 18 to 29 its
north star
this comes after researchers sounded the
alarm about the platform's potential for
damage to young users mental health
still i should mention this has not hurt
facebook's bottom line the company said
its revenue rose 35 from july to
september and it recorded almost 9.2
billion dollars in profit that's up 17
from last year so the question is always
will this actually impact the business
bottom line and he also zuckerberg i was
on the earnings call he mentioned the
metaverse we spoke about this yesterday
yesterday as this next iteration of the
social media company moving beyond a
social media company and into the
virtual space so a lot of questions
there guys yeah if they want the age
range from 18 to 29 to be their north
star is there rebrand for a new
demographic
i mean it's a good question right
they're competing with companies like
tick tock now i was actually
very fascinated that their north star is
these younger users when older users are
the folks who are signing on to facebook
these days so
it's a it's a very ambitious north star
for the company to be honest with you
guys and i'm sure that metaverse will be
popular though with that 18-29 group
yeah absolutely it's the future thank
you lori